- All right. Let's end this off
with one last feel-good story.
This is 'What I'm Liking'
(upbeat music plays)
A man known as Bayou Dave's on
a mission to save the world.
At least the bayou anyway.
Five days a week, he
combs Houston Waterway
scoopin' up seemingly
endless pockets of trash
that's destroying the area's ecosystem.
And to prove just how bad
the situation has become,
he makes videos like this for
the world to see. Take a look.
(transition effect whooshes)
- [Dave] This is called a turnin' base.
We have to do something
about this, people.
Am I the only one that
wants to save the world?
Bayou Dave, signin' out!
- Well, we have him on the line right now
from Buffalo Bayou
Partnership, let's say hello
to Bayou Dave.
Dave, how are you, my friend?
(audience member cheers)
- Hey, Jay. How you doin'?
- This is like your
life mission, isn't it?
- Yes, this is my life's mission.
I've been at Buffalo Bayou
Partnership for 12 years
and since I've been here,
I've had the opportunity to be able to
save the world.
- [Jay] Yeah.
- I never knew how bad the
pollution was until I got here.
And since I've been here,
we've added containment booms,
and we've gotten 12 dump
trucks of trash per week,
from the bayou.
- [Jay] Wow.
- [Dave] We feel like this is
important to save the world
and other people need to know about it.
- [Jay] Now, why is
this work in this video
so important to you?
- Because I realized people
just don't know.
- [Jay] Yeah.
- They just don't know that
the trash is out there.
And it hit a soft spot with
me when I saw all the animals
that were affected by the trash.
We have,
the snake population was
down when I got here.
Turtles, the osprey,
it was only one osprey.
One neighboring osprey when I got here.
Now we have four or five breeding pairs.
So we know that the water
quality is getting a lot better.
And we know that if we don't
do something, no one will
and Buffalo Bayou Partnership
is a non-profit organization
so there's some things we
put together with duct tape
and bubble gum, but we
do whatever we need to do
to try to make it work.
Failure's not an option.
- [Jay] Well, that's great.
And maybe the politicians
will come in to try to save
their fellow snakes, you know?
(audience members exclaim)
'Cause they have,
(Dave laughs)
they got, you know,
well, they got something in common.
They see their own brethren in there and
they're, "Oh! We gotta save this bayou!"
So let's get those politicians
- Jay.
- No, you can't be
shaking your head, Dave.
Yeah, okay.
(audience members laugh)
Well, that's great, my friend.
I'm liking your post right now.
Keep up the good work, my friend.
We applaud you.
(Jay claps)
Thank you so much for what you do.
And that's not all. Our
season-long partners,
Pilot Pen, makers of G-2, the go-to pen
of The Kelly Clarkson Show wanna honor
ultimate overachievers
like this gentleman.
So, they're writing you
a cheque for $1,000.
(audience members applaud)
So thank you very much, Dave.
(Jay claps)
Congratulations, buddy.
There you go.
(Jay claps)
- Appreciate it, Jay.
- [Jay] There you go,
you got it, my friend!